yeah holy [ __ ] guys I am so [ __ ]
sorry every stream I'm sorry guys round
of applause for Amazon guy I finally got
the cables but at what cost you guys
hear me alright no trolling allowed
today no I'm sorry can't handle a just
say it's fine and we can get going how
does it sound like
how does my epic voice sound like I
can't even [ __ ] hurry
testing testing pee pee testing the size
of my pee pee pretty good pee pee I
would say oh there's the delay in audio
my bad I can fix that I forgot to fix
that
did that do it let me change
bing-bong bing-bong bing-bong bing-bong
yeah it looks pretty good
damn I'm good at fixing [ __ ] now yeah
hell yeah this is camera look better
should I use my phone from now on
[ __ ] out that fix my hair yeah okay
nice
can you guys hear my playstation I don't
have I don't have any headphones working
[ __ ] I didn't have time to set it up you
know what it's not gonna be perfect
today we waited long enough
that looks good yeah I like this I feel
like yeah like [ __ ] sake okay somewhat
better
it disappears when I click on a okay
I'll just have to do it like this Boosh
oh now no I'm fast at fixing stuff yeah
are you like that [ __ ] that looks
unsymmetric whatever who cares
we're not here for symmetry
okay so another thing I want to check is
the delay between the gameplay and me
speaking so just tell me if this is
synched or not when I hit right it will
go right or left
so right left right laughs it seems to
bit off doesn't it I can see just from
my mouth left right left
okay I'll reduce it delay a little bit
[Music]
if my brain can do that
I removed 200
[Music]
okay so let's try that again right life
yeah that seemed better right
[Music]
seems good enough
big brain all right the moment we've all
been waiting for me playing as a bee for
us
ten hours who's excited ten now we're a
bee hi you guys waited for this [ __ ]
haven't played a game in two days I
remember how you play it now doesn't
matter nothing matters anymore there's
no point to anything in life and the
game looks good on this display I got
this like panic display that I can't
plug in my headphones - I got the cheap
one okay yeah sue me I bought a cheap
display and now I'm paying the
consequences how's the clock in the door
that's more important maybe there's
another way in I don't have as good
internet here people have been saying
that he's a self-insert like the
developer looks like him some people say
he put himself in there but I think he
addressed it or something why you killed
Joel why you spit on Joel mace there man
bun while you do this I just go we
already did this boy slang you know I
don't trust anyone
guys please don't harass anyone that
made the game
I find that so cringy people taking it
way too far it's a game
I hit this game so much iron makes me so
angry when he killed your I need to
harass people now okay let me hate me my
all me my damn don't be no Mel stay with
Alice
I just hate Apple try to get that door
open find you to another way in
cool be careful let's see if we can get
all the Abbi anime deaf scenes that's
the goal here
why does Abby have guns and when she
already has them she'd only hit him
jesus [ __ ] christ they better go
through her workout routine that's all I
ask
isn't that right barrels see barrels in
this game bad game coincidence I don't
think so
try lower my boys game okay once I I did
actually turn it up I'll just turn
myself down a bit
is that better there's an aka in the
building things going you guys are the
best
I just want a steroid scene and then it
can be like oh okay well it makes sense
still the site like scars maybe they
gave up instead of healing Abbey take
steroids you're fine no health kids need
it long way down yeah yeah it cheese on
ah all right
but this
I assume I need to pull this up yeah did
I say that beer Abbi
her name is Debbie my bad my bad gamers
here we go
alright I'm glad this works
big brain you know okay Mel we're in
let's reload we're already reloaded nice
I feel such a lack of motivation to do
anything what it's a [ __ ] heat wave
in UK right now rest in peace UK gang
apparently hotter here than Bahamas I
think the news are saying oh there's the
pills get it Abbi takes pills it all
makes sense
I gotta increase her now how do I
increase this that's impossible
she's already maxed out what's the point
okay yeah sure oh my god
why is she's pregnant I mean not why is
she pregnant why are you here this is
something progressive where pregnant
women can fight - or some [ __ ]
it just seems irresponsible I don't I
don't get it check it out some kind of
boat workshop you could just easily have
a miscarriage for very bad for spare
parts
explain this to me I don't get it well I
can't thank Rio I can't crack bombs I
can't grab these I don't know Abby makes
pipe bombs that's right
that damn the game looks good I keep
forgetting here we go can upgrade [ __ ]
to make us feel bad that's better yes I
got season pass Manny you don't ever get
pregnant I'm doing my best
replace that what's better
there's an 8k behind the stairs oh
really
accuracy everyone said capacity now for
[ __ ] sake guys be quicker next time
alright who said accuracy shame pp cut
off
I saw someone say it and I clicked then
Alban Nilson
pp chopped off you [ __ ] up Abby I'll
pin or Debbie whatever your name is
you're done
TP Wall of shame go home I know we were
attacked but okay now if you make no
still nice Dabba Dabba Dabba Dabba do
subscribe
outro darkness and redness then
whiteness
yeah there's safe here I'll look for it
baby armor oh yeah
I'll hold it here
yeah crank broke just lift that Abey
Abey look a hatch Manny just hang tight
we're gonna find a way up to the roof
it's her safe are you gonna [ __ ] with
me we didn't check out dealer to ride
with us no no stop Abby stop go away
Abby no good biscuit nugget in a [ __ ]
what do you want pregnant why have you
been avoiding me I wasn't avoiding you
come on you've barely said anything to
me since Jackson I don't know I guess I
was
she walks slow nothing to each other you
don't think Joel deserve what do you
look there were you guys smoking some
horse I just I just wish I didn't take
part in that oh my god stop it please
for the love person could do that right
I'm not saying that let's see if there's
a way to the hatch all right you guys
damn almost missed 18 pills okay maybe I
didn't look here fine
you guys win can Abby just punch the
safe open
is that the plan I like ideas by killing
people is that some kind of identity
like Abby already [ __ ] did she go
she never all right booster preggy break
in one boost jump this crossbow thing
ba ba ba ba baby ding dong ding dong
ding ding ding I just changing on here
okay I have to look at it so what's your
idea um one sec I can read your dumbass
comments better what are you doing
getting us out of here okay just go slow
your being pregnant
Oh center of gravity I'll take you eight
she's pregnant would dude there's a
[ __ ] phone
how much stuff did I miss
sorry gang what now she's Frankie with
her baking Jesus Christ guys all right
where's the crossbow thank you
oh my god dude am I still alive
am i selling
holy [ __ ] windows just try to reboot my
set windows is automatically rebooted
itself
foxy what a dick move in my life
[ __ ] you windows you can't do that I
think I'm still alive with my camera
[ __ ] up oh my god [ __ ] dick move
dude
you you restart now your restart now
that's what you're doing I [ __ ] up my
camera in there what happened
sorry guys
should work
okay there we go
yeah I'm back god [ __ ] damnit today
man it's just not my day
let's just hope it doesn't happen again
come on Sade are you gonna help me or am
I just gonna jump up [ __ ] sake I
wasn't paying attention we can use the
forklift or whatever it's called
people say turn up my mind I'm on the
floor right now she opened the door
oh how this is about to go here anyway
thanks okay getting closer to the hatch
let's see
all right I guess this is jump time ha
dice no so close camera is delayed
kidding me it was a ladder
hey now it slice of us it ain't last
summers without ladder I was wondering
when the ladders come up it's a nice
boat Mike is a little quiet huh see if I
can do something about that
is it better now sorry better now
there's a catwalk running to the hatch
how do we get to the castle autumn
all right where the [ __ ] don't put this
lighter and then
he gave you a heart attack was it loud
I'm sorry my fingers late
my parents are sleeping there's a
crossbow in the boat I'll put this back
I want to check inside the boat what
it's too loud no it's not shut up I
don't trust you guys anymore
all right what do we got this will come
in handy David versus Goliath how about
that get in the boat I'm in the boat
guys crashed ships instant stealth kills
damn kind of want to try that
that's cool that they get different
crafting stuff at least some variation
ain't nothing else in here
I don't need a [ __ ] hint I'm not
stuck I'm really good at puzzles
alright watch this first try okay first
right here we go first trying told you
totally I'm good at puzzles
okay that's promising
holgie gamers oh yeah I should heal and
then I should grab this thanks thanks
guys
pregnant lady goes first come on
walk the plank walk what is that face
what is he doing
[ __ ] do I do now now what that rope here
how the [ __ ] am I gonna get that rough
guys I have a feeling I shouldn't that
place it here okay we place it here am I
just supposed to use the ladder
why am I still stuck the rope is on the
boat no it isn't the back oh there's a
binge oh my god guys remember what the
video I said I broke my ass this is what
broke my ass this is it
this is what I lined it on when I was 17
I sat here steering the boat like a
captain like an epic boss okay my friend
was here doing whatever the [ __ ] I don't
know and then I go to sit down
he moves I'm supposed to grab him to
like sit down more easy boom asked went
right up that thing right up ten feet
deep and that's how I lost my and that's
how I made your mother your mother okay
sorry nice Hey look I solved the puzzle
before there was a puzzle that's big
brain
I wouldn't recommend doing them I
couldn't walk home for the entire week
and everyone made fun of me hard
especially when I look down it's not one
of those wounds where you break your leg
and people are like wow that's so cool
no it's just like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's wrong with you it wasn't even my
fault
you're supposed to speed run I'm sorry
okay okay okay they are Manny be right
down
okay look jump baby jump almost there
but we can cut through that rail yard
you wanna get off the roof first use
Lube next time with no what kind of hard
to imagine you being afraid of anything
I'm not as fearless as you think please
I could never do the surgery stuff you
do it's you freaked out about [ __ ] it
out slide down you think I don't feel
the same way Oh for what it's worth my
dad always said you were his best
student he did the only city was an
idiot I can't believe this 10 hours of
this it's just hey maybe by that'll be
like whoa Ben quiet out here I really
feel for Abby now I was so wrong about
all romance to the FOB and we get back
home I'm gonna find a couch watch a
movie 10 hour of dabby
that's right
fabbi you have an axe and giant muscles
you can open that door stop defending
what's drink which movie strong
questions movies the one with come see a
man the girl who writes the world oh I
love that one drink my mascara from the
party last week
excuse me yeah yeah I'll save some for
you oh I could definitely go for a drink
right now if I wasn't so pregnant yeah
we know you're pregnant
Jesus Christ stop talking about it guys
down this way okay more jungle area i
miss ellie already Emily's I know keep
your eyes open
not that I can see I'm not crawling
we're fun what are you doing
yeah it's so [ __ ] hot I bought an AC
I didn't know I've seen enough I don't
have time to plug it in before the
stream I really wanted to I think I can
actually go underneath here Abby too fat
sorry Ellie could have done it
my crack the ship now
worse things worse we throw the bottle
okay no bottle tossing I guess we're
going to Train
let's two of them
reload the bottle thanks guys just
waiting for them for two separated obey
she [ __ ] chokes then oh my God look
at her face right where the [ __ ] did
that noise that be dying
it's the zebra strain Oh God be bed
no God waters here thank you
[Music]
I'm behind
come on just show yourself that one of
ours
apparently they're reopening cinemas in
UK now
that's all I had about that I won't even
go pretty good south not gonna line it's
raining for you guys well lucky you
this weather sucks oh okay another one
bites the dust reopening restaurants in
Emily tank right go Netherlands oh
there's more okay we'll do the old
bottle training they always fall for
this idiots do you think they fell for
it maybe not here's a good night yes oh
look they're both crippled the crippling
nothing wrong with being crippled at all
how this software all right where's the
dirt
I don't think it died show yourself
trying to get those headshots okay cool
let me reload my break and we're good to
go
oh [ __ ] that it I don't see any more on
me let's go
did the armor work [ __ ] you too then
goddamn
wish I had an armor it's not fair
sorry dog you
sorry bye Oh oh my god
oh I messed up her old jar dude oh she
looking like I'm knees joking
amnesia monster yeah this is the lowest
I can have the volume without me
actually hearing in something so if
probably will leak a little bit sorry
about that
I'll get headphones on the next live
stream it's a dead end
yeah there's a rocket launcher top of
the Train alright check it out on the
next playthrough I want it to be too
easy
really thanks for the tip
I miss hunting gun it's like dynamic
microphone [ __ ] you're just talking
about this setting it might be a little
better
can you please say happy birthday for my
brother happy birthday shadow girls
brother yeah we're almost there
you can craft El Diablo
scope really I'm just gonna keep going
we're speedrunning through here
I'm not gonna look at everything on the
IV run okay all right watch this brick
see if I can hit him hey dog
that body
I'd be such a hero always something
violent for the greater good
I watched a donkey's review on it which
was interesting because he praised the
game a lot and I think that was
unexpected cuz he hated the first one
yeah I know it's loud up my back I could
maybe turn down a little bit there was
one thing he said that was so funny
[ __ ] if I remember
that's up it's like
one bad act can inspire inspires up
there some [ __ ] like that I don't
remember exactly and then but one good
deed can inspire others as well
that's why Abbey [ __ ] murdered Joel
after Joel's saving his life her life oh
man it's [ __ ] game tearing people
apart let them run
okay I'm with my mic a little farther
away
maybe that will do it Hey once I wash it
down
[Applause]
all right now it's turned out in a line
okay that might be better is it that
loud
whoops you want to see the gameplay too
bad you want to see Abby's guns too bad
squeeze this as hard as you can
don't even feel it
hey we got to
I might be better okay he's got a
gunshot wound to the hand now they're
all careful with her now they're all
like closer to my neck
yeah boys this is it almost a company
come on it's this way
those are the gameplays do not know not
to ask oh how about this
she should be out
yeah
no one ever complains that the game is
too loud
people always complain about the
opposite hey I got here come on girl
Thank You Kent it's better these new
recruits I know there's no frame I can't
be [ __ ] is this one of those days
we're just gonna have to go with it just
know I can't really hear the game too
well so if I don't hear something
obvious don't be mad okay checking in
hey you do what you got for us
no assignment just says report to Isaac
both of us yeah can you hear this never
be here you should make sure miles okay
first well now now the game is - for
[ __ ] sake
last time I just nailed it right away
it's like boom perfect settings we're
gonna cut the line again
Abbie or have you learned your lesson
pick another Amazon
hey there Eddie
okay Abbi Marisa yes
heard about your ambush where'd they hit
you right around here the other
warehouses [ __ ]
they keep slipping past our lines hey
you know where Isaac is he was here a
few minutes ago okay
Thanks look around
we need more lookouts
this is cool I like this part of the
game this is really fun Oh God are you
seriously compelling about the frame who
gives a [ __ ] god [ __ ] damn me for
some reason I can't [ __ ] see it it
doesn't show up on my screen ain't
nothing I can do about it oh my god now
it shows up oh my god are you serious
okay
y'all baby's happy now anything else you
want me to rub your butt no wait that's
not a weird feel like we should operate
this one cool nice gun stability sure
I'll take it
I guess is the first time setting up it
takes a bit more annoying time I'm
trying to speed Ryan thanks this is the
average speed run our world record yet
so far we're on track for the world
record Abbey shoots why is this so
tempting to have a gun
what's wrong with me put away your gun
happy Thank You whoo geez [ __ ] psycho
we're supposed to check out
looks pretty bad how doc [ __ ] now called
ones :
cancel bottom that actual colons
donating hey man
feeling better pain meds are kicking in
so yes hanging firm legit question mind
keep most of my fingers I had a good
really good time hanging out am i right
that was fun god we've got the devil hey
guys are you doing melon just a few more
stitches and I'll be good as new
you guys need to convince this how's the
baby is the baby okay you got it hey I
need some you're not allowed to go and
roller coaster there's so many things
you can't do it I'm pregnant I'll just
be here bed combat relaxing
yeah Nora have you had a chance to get
everything inspired Chad to buy it hell
yeah really well the baby's vitals were
a little elevated but I'm not worried
someone should get word to Owen I want
if chad is perfect the way is don't need
to diet but if you wanted to
he'd look hella good I need to show you
buy something follow me I feel like
quarantine is a good time to oh my god
change your habits to more healthy want
ours
yeah and we're coming in by the hour I'm
supposed to feel bad this game makes me
feel like a sociopath
it's like isn't this sad you killed the
dog before what's wrong with you look at
all these dead bodies isn't this
terrible
Oh Danny [ __ ] he was like a father to me
I don't know a few days back there were
s in the chat for Danny he was my
favorite character after Joel and this
morning the guards found Danny collapse
finds a perimeter fence he'd walked
himself back with a bullet in his
stomach just ask icicle support da you
should have won her arm as far as I can
tell this plane it's going back that way
that's fried but he gave me then a
[ __ ] look and then he told me to keep
quiet about it which means you can't say
[ __ ]
oh it's a big boy [ __ ] it out I'm sure
he's fine
where is Isaac
I'll be discreet last I heard he was in
the apartments
I'm gonna go check up on now so we know
where you guys find out yeah
god damn this [ __ ] game it's so crazy
why the hell hasn't Isaac sent out a
search party for ollie maybe he hasn't
just a bit more
all right how do we speedrun five hours
of Danny next can't wait we're looking
for Isaac can't wait for the Danny
flashbacks I just want to see the ending
at this point in time for a game see
what I do around I don't no spoilers I
don't miss this place
[ __ ] always hated the smell
god this scene goes on forever no
wonders 10 hours I wouldn't mind a few
minutes with these guys that's the first
hour pass yet hey guys how you doing
Cole so he takes prisoners that's cool
didn't see those in Ali's camp but
whatever yeah you need to go up Essex in
there Oh do you know if he'll be long so
again when you two arrived
sir Abby Mannion
Hey
look away kids don't look don't let him
fall asleep oh it's the peepee ritual
let's go up Abby should do it come on
it's more ran into some trouble
what's gonna happen to you guys if you
throw me again jury okay it's just a
warning
snip-snip I was hearing more of that
I've never seen the base this box can
tip for sure give it another day we're
still waiting on some units what's going
on boss
these small skirmishes
can't keep going like this then what we
could try another truce
how long before some [ __ ] on their
side sideline the whole thing no it has
to be all of them
Sara would try attacking their Island
not like this oh my god everyone let's
see never ends it's a big storm a few
days out we're gonna use it to mask our
approach you two are gonna lead the
first wave I'm just waiting for it to
tie into when Jola rates the hospital
I want Owen what are you and Dana
getting back
Danny dead do you not remember Nora no
secrets between the salt lake crew
someone okay you can cut this I don't
know I felt like I need to watch it
you shot Danny apparently to protect
some scars [ __ ] excuse me
that's not Owen you got it wrong you're
saying Danny used his last breath to lie
to me sir
people here dad's story Oh instead this
is four years after Julian I knew that
they'll gun him down for support and I
suggest you all stop gossiping about it
let me go after him I'll walk him back
in we'll get to the middle you said
yourself the storms if no we've only got
one shot at this and this is bigger than
any of us
yeah and that HEPA looks definitely
bigger to no one it looks like he's
trying to pull off getting a plastic
fridge - bird mine if he turns up then
fine I'll give him the benefit of the
doubt
and we'll get to the bottom of it I need
you Abbi yeah
yeah
again
good why do you guys do today huh is
there I'm good with the plans and go
through roster doing exciting more
exciting than this grab some food talk
later
yeah no way a wing killed an you were so
much ignorance right
what no Abbi don't
I'll be back by morning you just gotta
cover me till then I said we'll kick
your ass number four the assault
you heard him only do it if Owen saud
there how the hell are you going to find
him I know where he'll go
thank God thank you thank you
no three years earlier Gabi's with her
dad
that's a cool shine all right why don't
you come on over and enjoy this view
with me then it's great its best oh come
on we made it all the way up here just
so you could wimp out on the last two
nine hours left boys yeah we got this
yes
you don't wants to get up here so hmm
all right here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna get your ass over here
sit on the edge or you can go down here
on the kid seat and look at this view
with me I can't miss training really not
even oh my god
is this Danny Knight is this the [ __ ]
Danny flash package happen talk about it
hell yeah it's getting late yeah
okay it's Owen
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh don't don't do not it's too
high you know I don't think I can live
like this anymore Abbi
Owen I'm serious I will break up with
you oh I always love you yes
damn it looks so good are we jumping and
there's some Assassin's Creed [ __ ] all
the water will disappear doesn't feel
fair
[Music]
a bee and down here you [ __ ] you've
jumped and I missed it it's all you
drowned and you came to my rescue
no came to make sure she's drowned I
found something no I'm not enjoying
myself
shut up I think you're gonna have to
follow me to see it
[Music]
usually stretching in the water oh and
we have to go back we will once you see
that it's coming to you don't sing
cringe what are you gonna do kick out a
bunch of displaced fireflies with
nowhere else to go shake my head my head
find out just come see this thing
what do we get for the [ __ ] did he go
god damn it I'm trying to speedrun this
thing I gotta go through here nope
should we draw on her can you do it I
don't need a hint
I think Debbie's dying I don't think I
took a big enough breath and I honestly
don't care
oh [ __ ] Jackson rest in peace game over
happy ending alright guys thanks for
watching last of us this was a game I
liked the ending
loke want to get all the Debbie Dex
[Music]
you know keep going
I'm waiting for the flashback where she
plays gold for their dad is that
happening
you can spoil at if that happens I just
want to know ya crazy I think it's like
one of those oh one kind of cute not
kind of like Jesus Christ pop out
I saw the seal the other day it's
covered in spots
they don't have spots they're brown
those are sea lions no no you don't know
how it's been running I know what I saw
with my eyes hey give me a hand with
this yep I guess we know omen is
what is this place
well clearly this is some sort of
theater but for fish all I want to do
that
I sure rooster that's my you guys still
crushing over Owen you think this elbow
is part of the show
yeah looks like somebody turn us into a
makeshift dock or something don't check
it out get in the boat daddy could there
be a zombie in here if I fail this is
like a zombie
oh they're not gonna fit you'd a being
my family came through look at these
drawings
I wonder what happened to him Jesus
Christ now or it got killed by scars
okay so we have this an optimist
son dad mom and the dog and still a
better story than last of us is that
gonna be nice well the lion what the
hell happened to you hey it's that robot
from before we've seen that that's funny
and people rate this 10 out of 10 Wow oh
god I can't look at these do you think
there's more to see of course let's go
kids should add directly the game now
can I lie young Abbi looks kind of fresh
but you guys are simple for Abby now
what the hell I thought we had an
agreement
she looks human here at least
and you can get through that give me up
there yeah okay make a bunch of kids are
making noise on sites what my host right
so we take a quick look around and then
we head right back
[Music]
that work that great do you guys see me
getting hit in the head because that
didn't happen nothing bad happened I did
not get hit in the head no problem you
guys soon dad I took my way longer
mine's opened the window it's our fault
what I miss fabbi died
cool surely the fishes in here will be
old dead
it became from here and the other one
here you'll see that everyday
okay you saw it goddamn it him in the
pain I installed those blinders in the
back oh [ __ ] this is awkward
I installed them but I didn't realize
you can't open the window anymore it's
so awkward
goddamnit big brain yeah let me let me
know if you guys need to have installing
blinders in the floor no problem you
imagine this place filled with people
kids laughing I think we need to put
higher advisors can't be [ __ ]
looks like a bunch of twitch streamers
oh man
I'm claiming this place it's mine you
can visit you should just use likes tape
he really actually speedrun in my bag
nice you are to the first not a great
start
max plays yeah we're gonna find the kids
and die dead we're gonna find them died
can you go in here
I've been going here no that's max place
where do I go then abby's it's in better
basically all right that's good yeah get
them to break the rules to let's see how
much trouble were in when we get back
it's a base here they are yeah I'll read
the note in a sec so basically what
divides the game is if you like sin
Darris or not which confirms that if you
like this game then your ascent okay
it's honourable that you respect your
father but you have to see is trying to
control you to make you feel like you're
still a child because she's too afraid
to act like a man you deserve to be
surrounded by a community that can
foster a strong spread like yours max
even more so he's so impression of all
if you care about your brother you will
get him out of there before can't be
bothered reading more your mama is a
little blower
can I look at that
would you mind I think this is our boat
captain [ __ ]
Abby its tier five muscle increased to
strong dad I'm taking max away from me
he can't spend his life locked inside
this rotten building all he'll do is
take on your weaknesses when the
soldiers killed mom you just stood there
like a coward what kind of example is
that you should have gotten angry should
have made them hurt okay I want max to
see what it looks like when people are
willing to stand up for what they want
maybe when we'll come back done it
someday if we do I hope you're not still
sitting in your stupid [ __ ] chair Oh
No Oh on the bright side family's keys
we should lift the body so skeleton he
does it on top with a whale or something
I just don't understand how anybody
willingly joins us cars why not because
they're an insane cult that's why I'm
gonna accuse these people will refer to
the fireflies the terrorists fanatics
it's not the same I'm just saying don't
say [ __ ] like that of the stadium okay
okay all right
let's go to max place there is max pace
that'd be my guess
dude his artistry improved over time not
gonna lie I'm gonna try those keys oh
yeah this part is basically a flashback
inside a flashback
after blacks yes got it
storytelling guys you just don't get it
damn painting this must have taken
forever
first don't tell me you want to go down
there come on
oh and last thing I promised last thing
just don't look good so how much is life
how many hours are left let's go it's
gotta be like 1 hour left I can't jump
who doesn't let me
trust me I try these I'd love to meet
this kid I mean he's a scar maybe you
have Jesus
I sure hope that Oh get on in here
we're going for the world record I'm a
speedrun
Oh see that told you there was parted
[Music]
all right go back to camp now that's
enough look away kids
you need to go back to camp come on Abby
this this isn't it
you are disgusted by it why what you
mean I'm sorry don't be sorry
talk to me
I know all the leads have dried up but
the jewels still out there you know
what can I do
let's go back we could still make
training
how did Abby rank up so much if she
skips training a [ __ ] you grab Oh
what were you hanging out with the seals
I'm sorry
I told you already don't be sorry
damn are we supposed to like Abby or
what's going on getting hints here and
there but nothing really nothing so for
her she ate a samurai wills he's there
let's get over the roof before someone
sees us okay we're back to the first
flashback now
nice no we don't know what happened I
was wondering when that was happening in
him I mean if you really killed up let's
reload our Blake brick yeah Blake we'll
call it bloody I do appreciate you
helping me sneak out like this
how are you getting to the query house
if I throw it at Han I do any patrols I
get spotted for sure I'll rough it
aquariums do Westar here
keep following the sunroom I can't come
in with you [ __ ] out ways in a break no
with these many scarce in the area
Minnie please all right you know best
it's their safe in here come on
committed a loot for speedrunning over
here but we do need to loot [ __ ] out
I swear I saw something else there you
go
yeah more steroids
don't lute speedrun my bad
[ __ ] we came from here hey thanks yeah
and other stuff you're right she already
has the guns the lineups we don't need I
can handle all these solutions clear you
go quicker if you jump all right wish me
luck when you find him don't hit him too
hard I'll do my best
seriously watch yourself out there see
why we're not going out with pregnant
lady what the hell
just follow sunset all right let's go
take a dump
I still want to upgrade stuff that's
like the most fun part of the game
all right refresh me what we're doing
here we're looking for
Owen yeah I knew that all right guys
question you're in the middle of the
hallway
you see daya be on the other side she
starts doing this what do you do that B
runs with scissors she's crazy
only thing that can kill her that's cool
Ellie can't jump up with these that's
funny well maybe she can we're going
here nope then watch that polling
you guys see your way in
don't think I can make this jump
it's right here I'm trying to be fast
now boys so fast it's a note [ __ ] that
that's a shoe I thank God I almost
missed those I'm supposed to go here
I'm Sean oh yes okay another one that's
[Applause]
she dead
now she [ __ ] wasted my silencer dumb
[ __ ] come on
all right let's do this again
well should I upgrade listen mode yeah
that was pretty good except that I'd
never use it [ __ ] nailed it why can
we jump down we're not jumping down damn
generous
what the hell Oh been watching food Wars
on Netflix it's so crazy it's for kids I
mean definitely not for kids but guide
you right off a cliff yeah likewise Abbi
likewise the premise of the show is that
this guy cooks food and makes people
orgasm when they eat it and it's so
[ __ ] weird I have to watch with
really low volume it's for kids that I
mentioned they goddamn it I kind of want
to try the ships love food wars food
Wars in a nutshell yeah that's it
is it bad that I don't remember where we
came from
this is [ __ ] take them out this is a
lot of them it's only those two this is
gone I can't be [ __ ] nice so ships are
good for speed run then I need tape so
bad
that a clicker G says Abbi you must
click they're out of the game oh there's
another one
she don't need guns
[ __ ] I keep getting something explosions
but I never had the other material thank
you all right so like two hours left or
how much more Abbi do a guy this whole
way they said follow this son I feel
like I should look there but also
speedrun so let's go
all right that answers that god damn it
smashing brakes
more steroids zebra protein pills it's
all we need
it's all good
safe behind the register was it it
looked like a fridge I saw it too you
don't mean this do you
really you guys are making me do this
and the bakery
is that mid 30 euro Kuni no I'm not
reading that wrong I know that I want to
but I forgot it
so I don't know it babies tiny it's
probably Chinese
as Chinese hey hey ooh
[Music]
I'll never find them
Oh God what the [ __ ] goddammit
zombies are smart now I thought they
were supposed to be done rip no rip
sneaking so for a second mr. go yeah no
I don't laugh at babby no no no
i legit feel like I would I probably
wouldn't even finish the game if I
wasn't live-streaming it oh great they
wrote down the combination 6 8 9 6 8 9 6
8 9 6 8 9 I'm not gonna remember that 6
8 9 6 8 9 6 8 9 6 8 9 6 8 9 6 8 9 6 6 6
[ __ ] whoa goddamn shoddy like a melody
and 6 9 4 21 3 3 7 was that it double
barrel
why do I never get the bottles [ __ ] I'm
spending this time much time looting and
[ __ ] G says oh my god I don't need to
fight anymore how do I pick up guns Hey
look his Dark Souls
what's wrong with you die be steroids
got her acting up it's normal
alright this probably window here yeah
nothing we can crawl through that though
they're so safe you see I said it was in
the bakery oh here we go
always watch anime sub always trying to
learn Japanese come on so that's us
that's house that's small did I get it
right all right where was the bakery I
already got the shotgun
yeah you did okay I'll take your word
for it
sorry where's the safe
I didn't see any the purple sign shop
see that's how you talk to me that's how
you say it
the purple sign all right okay so yeah
I'll just break the windows thanks guys
just treat me like I'm a toddler that's
how we get through this finally I got a
bottle nice no all right so 69 420 it
was 96 eh
[Music]
okay six eight nine six eight nine
thanks guys
thank you I'm playing on a Playstation
pro but the texture standard seems to
struggle sometimes
this is reloaded yeah after came the
enemy with a strike for a short time it
will also be the only tank will also be
a strike our maximum le hell yeah let's
punch through the game one punch why man
I feel like they could have used this
time to make led bond with Gianna or
Dina chooses dad you just keep coming
back here I think that would have been
because I I still don't believe them
like I have to read this
nope I didn't you want peace easy
stay on your Island
skip those okay you turned a crazy
person in on the murder yes
what are we fine
this is for weapons nice
can you play through the game and
missing all that Fabri funny okay sweet
Gordon free ma'am yeah they're just
walking circles absolutely did I do it
on purpose
of course
am I supposed to go here this is all
closed stop I was a ladder here no it's
a note no no no that's a big ass dude
what'd I miss
confused noises
other side of the truck
oh my god are you serious no I don't
think I'm supposed to be here unless I
can jump there a bee dies wait what the
[ __ ] god damn it found it speed run
continues guys I don't want to go there
uncharted I think I figured out why my
brain is so foggy lately I feel like Oh
God
they didn't see me just follow the
yellow thing thanks guys
I haven't eaten any sugar and it's
really hot I didn't know you're supposed
to eat sugar but I guess sometimes it's
good
made some strawberries and now my brain
back someone like 54%
[ __ ] it's hot in here guys but heat does
not help either where are you
you need 15 grams daily
yeah I've not been getting that I don't
eat I don't eat sweets that I don't like
it then I notice my brain be like brah
really hard to focus there's no sugar in
G fuel and I only drink G fuel in water
and protein I'm on that Abby diet
so many books it's so much wasted God
I've never been curious to read
something from before the Cataclysm no I
kind of want to just go in and punch bow
for the nod with one of their books
there - why is she how dare she faced a
bee shoot dumb [ __ ]
we're shooting me
I like to snake through this I don't
know why I'm just so incentivized to
play the game properly I'm so like
alright let's go are they gonna do shoot
us Abby can't die this is a flashback
all right there
guess we'll just go in there
[Music]
ah don't need guns
oh yeah that's the guy we shot not even
coming up guess not
I'm not getting any bottles dude
speedrun it's not that small
hey all day
man I was more comfortable on the floor
[ __ ] chair stuck
what's all this it's okay I'm trying to
ask our can let's put a scope on this
can't afford the [ __ ] I can't read all
of that nice I like this gun more than
the shotgun
it's more fun increased capacity no
nothing else
sweet there we go
what even if you reload you're serious
she reads fast he's a speed reader Oh
oh my god my Microsoft saying I have to
wait an hour and then it's gonna restart
we're gonna have to speed up this
speedrun it's literally forcing me to
update my computer god [ __ ] damn it
why do they do that
don't worry we can speed run we can put
eight hours into one hour no problem
can you just do like you do on the phone
where you you can reschedule eight I
think I've already done that like six
times how do I stop it it seems like
hide you okay no problem for Debbie
Gavin um today did
Oh God oh she didn't even see it die be
stealth Queen hell yeah oh oh that was
not silent
this is one
I can smell you
thank you anyone else
yep
a lot more shoot him in the foot Jesus
thanks babe
jeez thanks I need a moment here damn
someone more badass than a bee Oh God
this is these two right well that takes
care of that can we upgrade the hammer
that'd be dope yes
oh there's more
Oh how did he not know where I am where
do you go
I'm trying to go as fast as I can is
that the last guy
hey look it's uncharted yeah we're on
chart oh that's tinkling oh god it's the
big one there's more Abi's no that's
impossible no one's stronger than Abbi
come on yeah Oh Abbi you [ __ ] dance T
the [ __ ] is wrong with you they just had
flex tape ready yes okay game over we
did it we did it guys thanks for
watching the livestream appreciate Oh
what is this Oh a flashback in the
flashback okay cool
I was wondering when I was gonna I was
wondering when they were just gonna
happen another flashback huh okay Abbi
needed protein IV needed refuel Oh
quick snack when you need to know that's
Owen okay gotcha
so what's up we got orders it's sort of
sort of you know what I didn't recognize
him before hold off on the Isaac talk
just it's him right yeah yeah here look
around
whoa look at this how did you do you
know just rip out some vines getting
some walls that's amazing
is Alice out here she's out with me now
this is gameplay I can move it with my
controller Abby can't help herself
choking things it developed at early age
nice good for the most part I mean she
can be really sweet must feel nice after
me
well that badass exterior will be pretty
sweet too best gameplay ever you have a
bad memory an elective memory my ear is
clicking
well this looks complicated don't touch
that
Abigail he's doing a science experiment
kind of making some prime hooch here if
you're nice I'll give you some
lucky me what am I doing here this is
urine come John what's wrong with you
people
this is Dan that's sexy though damn Luke
oh wait I thought it was two legs it's a
it's a baby one
sorry--but little one looks like two
legs that's hella sexy yeah there's a
toy boy I can hang something come on
oh sweet okay whoa
oh yeah Mel and I have this competition
thing going I don't think you would
enjoy it
it's pretty complicated I see what
you're doing and it's that's a pretty
elaborate toy okay
see those targets yeah there's a
baguette and as you can not Tony boy god
dammit I win you better write my name up
there you got it
oh sorry I keep forgetting that's one
proud of you
good practice actually more to go
[ __ ] it son oh hi
goddamnit oh my god I keep [ __ ] them
well I'm making it better
am I missing any
how Isaac would be a shame no can't do
that honey
thought I had them all I did it first
try that was one of the shark nose
that's great
you're good at everything shut up and
put me up on the wall I will later are
you scared of Mel finding out I was here
no she doesn't care so put me up on the
board
Owen all right calm down bruh this is -
boy it's not too bad come on let's not
be so negative
look I got a trophy that's cool right I
can go upstairs yeah
is it that boat captains damn it I
didn't see that one I saw it last time
bruh you didn't put a Santa hat on it
did you
what no that would be cool now it's the
pregnant lady ooh spicy drama after you
Oh
it's a crossbow here is this where we
get it taking that view [ __ ] finally
dude I've been waiting forever
our one has interesting taste in women
gotta say I'll try that
crossbuck coming soon he'll yell
whatever Philistine young male lying yes
obviously into this Christmas thing and
you lost your chance Abby it's our one
year you had your chance but you blew it
don't take it out on Joel
it's a horrible I think you can go [ __ ]
yourself no I wish someone loved me
enough to make me a stocking dude I
think I have those cups holy [ __ ]
there's someone who loves me what are
the odds
why are you in such a good mood am I
what's in those drink off to a win
tonight Jules brother he's at a
settlement out in Wyoming how do you
know that the fireflies you served with
him got picked up at the wall I thought
he'd quit like a decade ago yeah so have
these guys heard from him since it's a
lead I got to see it through okay but
you know that even if he is there and
you do find him he might not know where
Joel is right
you tell the others everyone's on board
god it's like stated animation
voice-acting gameplay again graphics but
this is what the story
Isaac's never gonna let that many people
go on face he already did it so Shane
who's more about justice than Isaac he
knows what Joel's done hey we're doing
this together great
am i playing no sweet eight hours left
let's go gamers we got this the most
action-packed scene alright we're back
to regular flashback that's cool
[Music]
outlast gang fit you're right they do
look like out laughs
my camera's still working yeah
well that looks cool goddamn
whoa he made you bet it hell alright
risk finally every bound to happen this
is on the trailer
No No
and I missed it
with sin
reason yeah Amy no
some weird harakiri [ __ ]
whoo damn Yura
where's the other apostate
clip her wings seriously me
oh how that hurts oh good night oh oh
that also hurts good thanks
Oh God socks are divine oh hey nice move
I gotta respect those moves oh okay
hey look at that
don't let her go I mean yeah
[Music]
you wanna help me out here Brice saved
your friend's life demons are coming
excuse me
cut her down she's one of them left
Hey damn it looks so real and then the
muscle comes out
dan there's the shot that's cool
watch your backs
some the hammer [ __ ] wouldn't thought
ahead little reference what up tree gang
I just aim shoot Danny
[Applause]
[Music]
okay well that hammer is no good he
missed a point blank are you going not
as bad as Eugene Brett at rest in peace
I miss Eugene so much goddamn there is
more that's interesting they call them
demons I know
[Applause]
really cool scene yet you sure you know
equal area
oh there's what but it being cool to
start with this why am I playing as a
being this is so weird
there must be something about her all
round hello
snack snack a roux let me just nibble on
those ears snack snack no let me just
tear this open for you guys
oh my god is actually it okay no problem
whoa oh it's a big one all right the
Battle of the Ancients how's your night
okay what the [ __ ] Oh cutscene by bang
no it isn't I don't think we want to get
hit by her oh she came to the double
stop double swinging it's I don't know
your move set yet okay we dead now no
triple and she does a triple alright
well it paid off it paid off anyway
that's a double that's a triple there we
go look away kids they're just sitting
there chilling you're right
all right we got our [ __ ] Bank sweet are
you wearing my backpack how dare you
so this is the upgraded one
go on
the baddest I love that you didn't kill
Joel it's cool
okay have any supplies you find not a
golden gun it's a flare gun no it's a
musket you need supplies this is hunting
this oh I saw comments earlier that's
said like oh there's a hunting rifle I
thought you guys were [ __ ] with me
ever since car is going after scars
before god dammit don't tell me I really
don't care oh yeah we don't have that
much
nevermind that's still not enough how's
your arm we can put good use of it
[ __ ] that
is a one-shot kill oh hell yeah let's
try it
I've got it so big here quick
run-through supplies
how many hours left
we got to be on like two hours life
doesn't happen no supplies except in the
bathroom yeah sweet we can make a Python
all right silencer might be better
actually now I changed my mind
go with that for now
is anyone gonna ban this checkers arm
I'm just picking up rags left and right
she's fine cool
I'm curious about these guys it might be
some interesting characters oh okay I
like this gun
hi there oh my god that was so I thought
I have a spot-on
I don't I don't even eat same franchise
hey Felix if you're the past well I
think 100% a crazy gang save your
bullets here yeah all right
he's kind of wanted to try it out sorry
sue me hate me that you're not to me
oh my white boy 30 my cocky in a minute
there's a lien because not the yeah nope
we're going down here oh [ __ ]
that'll do here another one
gasps okay in here
cool
you're welcome snack snack more ears
num num num num them know what quite
confident a be better not [ __ ] kill
these people she has a tendency of
killing people whose life gets saved
I can't include oh that's a lot I'll do
that eat the army of this person
well actually if you've noticed earlier
in the game there were already a lot of
food so he totally makes sense that
she's so buff
of course a premiere I'm trying guys I'm
really your attorney watch that arm so
she's wearing the haircut from the
people in the club the cult and she's
using the same kind of lingo as they are
but for some reason they go against them
hurry up all right now's a good time to
talk about with this car
[Applause]
no I'm hearin I'm Shivan thanks for the
tip of singing the ammo
are there more coming
more of them they open the game show
main aids oh my god unless you expect me
to claim
what the [ __ ] this happened oh my god
Oh share forgot the Explo
standing shoot yeah zero deaf guys feels
good man get up damn be just just give
me you're gonna hold on tight oh they
both have the Joker thing what the [ __ ]
I know focus on your breathing in it out
nice all right Sarah Trash Can anywhere
it's part of that thing yeah I figured
[Music]
try the doors make sure there are no
infected try the other ones I'm afeeling
we're gonna do something with that crane
look at the moon look at the head
Danny's cool any look let me just put
you down your sponge I put her down with
goddamn a breeze mussels are so goddamn
big that they protect their head from
breathing sports hey hey yeah you got it
it's the steroids they made her immune
they didn't need although this could
have been prevented
it just needs to be said
you know how to do that
cut that in the strips
I'm back
that'll do here eat this it's protein
okay that makes sense
make you strong
thanks for cutting me down
you see breeze sports I didn't notice I
attract whatever shape she's in
oh you're right because they explode
you'll be fine
alright damn I'm soloing I'm on ow
goddamn it I assumed we're gonna do
something with that [ __ ] crane it's
like Chico's gun could just put a giant
crane like that no reason or maybe it's
just a prawn [ __ ] if I know
so these were locked right
then what the [ __ ] we doing here boys
you can't climb this truck for some
reason yeah
people break soon holding your peace if
you have to pee just all day we all go
pee together okay that's what we do here
it's a bonding moment I just go over
here I know my brain is large
so yeah my brothers my brother soon we
will be together yes I do Uganda
knuckles voice in 2020 it's happy
okay yeah let's just find the crossbow
and then we'll we'll do a pee-pee break
we have 44
you can put a four-time scope on this
[ __ ] bad boy hell yeah I'll put a
[ __ ] okay we'll save for that we'll
save money for that that's fun
do I have enough now just look around
here a bit more are you winning son yes
dad I'm playing as a bee
of course I'm winning it's a 10 it's a
10 hour segment no one asks for but they
put it in of course I'm winning dead
yeah put a scope on that [ __ ] yeah
el Diablo 2.0 those points zero yes yes
yes
Akuma then devil I'm not the oblong it
is Akuma new day oh hey nice finally yes
I need em oh come on
oh I see
eyes an open window oh I heard somebody
bakumatsu
whip whip whip ftvp the PPP PPP PPP PPP
PPP oh look at that that's so cool
she looked like you enjoyed them
how're we doing we have 30 what about
the [ __ ] we can craft ships were a
lifesaver back there so I'll definitely
craft some Sarah that playthrough
speedrun not bad
actually this should be the only time
sir that doesn't count all right perfect
time hey guys
can they come up here okay we're gone
sorry my computer tells me to restart
[Applause]
later smell you later zombie hater
that was great yeah we need the AEK come
on war it's a sign for people great too
soon you got a whole day if you got to
go I respect that don't don't do
anything stupid okay but I can last a
little longer
whoa and this looks good
we got Fullman shame no games have foam
okay I'm gonna go up here and then
people break you ready okay Peavy break
run run
this is No
do you feel that sense of relief
we both cherry
this is a bonding moment what happened a
bead I'm okay
cool
you never have the [ __ ] model
so we're going for open sale right
that's the goal right that's the game
right that's epic
Abby stop pretending like you're better
than them okay because you and I both
know you ain't have [ __ ] better than
him
where's the bow then
I missed the Bell
possible
okay well let's make sure I don't miss
the grenade launcher then
that's right we came from a little bit
disorient then so where does the room we
weren't in a second gun there we go
there's an aka finally sweet I wouldn't
add dinner yet so I might have to wrap
up the stream in a 30 minutes maybe oh
my god that's a [ __ ] crossbow oh my
god I don't believe it I don't believe
it
it's real what what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
troll me about the crossbow or you oh
sorry I was such a perfect target all
right here we go
come on I hit him in the head it is in
the head now I thought the point that's
in the head too come on get me the
bullet back
Bill's here
must be a window or something
or a hole in the ceiling
the flip am I supposed to go
I wish I could speedrun the whole thing
gamers I really do
they're zombies oh there
I do believe you now having a little
earlobe that's a crossbow at the stairs
you weren't lying
thank you guys you don't get the
crossbows back crossbow bows
I heard more zombies over there
well there's a bazooka there's a chopper
Oh
if I find an a came my mind will be
[ __ ] blown
okay they're all in here
one two
three four how many tintern range [ __ ]
I'm getting ass cake I once on because
I'm gonna save ammo
okay that's took care of that Abby needs
no guns just punched him clearly doesn't
work
goddamn yeah I'm gonna stream tomorrow
as well to make up for the 10 hours
this is a man at dinner
sorry gamers
what's the best time to stream
around this time
maybe I'll do a little later one
what's your stand
[ __ ] sake this is what way
is that edgy
Angie
I miss a lightsaber [ __ ] oak Edgar don't
[ __ ] with these cables
this is not very speed run on me how am
I supposed to go
I've got Edgar's breathing I thought it
was a Samba it's so [ __ ] hot
I guess why I'm in the ocean today it
was so cute
3 p.m. is good ok here we go
I took your girl my paddleboard he
wanted to get on it
but he told the scared of water a little
bit he's like playful with it but he's
like cautious about water
so he went on the paddleboard so I went
out a little bit on it with him on top
and I don't know I don't know where
Eggar just decides I'm [ __ ] this I'm out
so he goes off my sense of photos of its
is so [ __ ] funny
he jumps off ok guys I'm telling I'm
telling story here story time right in
the bling er let's do some silencer
we good to get this one
are there any more in there I mean real
oh that's the wrong I think I learned it
all oh my god okay
[Music]
thank you all right just need
to get off this boat
as was a run here
very serious there's a safe here
this is one left to know how let's make
the shots count here [ __ ]
nope
[Applause]
all right what's the code what's the
code
okay so 70 1977
you better not be trolling me because P
P goes Knicks name
so yeah I was on the support again
there's the photo of him looking like
Jesus like right when you touch the
water before you fall in and then
there's the photo of him falling in and
it's literally just his leg sticking out
of the water like a submarine so [ __ ]
funny it was fine
hey cheers guys
hey maybe you guys aren't so bad after
all
[Applause]
why would you keep that book in a safe
craft incendiary shells oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah Oh
oh yeah oh hell yeah
I wish I knew that before
all right how do I get up above
get off the boat you're a terrible
itself well I'm not trying to stop but I
might do it but I love it Cheers thank
you
game Leslie playing over whatever you
feel like
this is where they tell me what the safe
code is the code of the safe right
before I die I mean why not level up
self do you think I need it
nailed it wait let's try that again
excuse me I'm not doing that again
[ __ ] you and the stream here after this
important stuff will go down important
stuff will go down you try the next
level up what's gonna don't spoil
10,000
excuse me
looks like a big shoot down area
that's not closest player
can't go anything the plants on it can't
go on it impossible
how am I supposed to go
is this the right spot
there's a boss fight
like we already did that
where am I going I know nobody's known
here we go
yeah I got it
that's how I can go out there but I
can't be bothered
all this big areas with no zombies are
our enemies this is me running
huh oh this okay we made it finally
totally ring nice we made it Owen Owen
Owen come on
hey remember when Joel was in this game
I remember mummy this is a cute game
about him a father reconnecting with his
lost daughter after losing you know I'm
trying to thank [ __ ] reconnecting after
losing his daughter finding hope in
humanity once again well here we are
playing as a bee for 10 hours
my expectations are so subverted right
now guys it's good right my expectation
noted we're suburban day don't you get
it no one expected this you don't get it
please
oh okay so my expectation
subverted expectation game alright so we
have a rope now and I can't go through
did I check in
okay so I can have this rope but I can't
always attach there okay
ah no that doesn't make it yeah I just
make sense then I can climb on the roof
yeah I know I can't do that
[Music]
there we go No
or yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
you're nervous me to bet Obon is a
zombie
I look for something here
that door looks pretty fun
no sorry gotta finish it about this
glass
all right Owens been eating this is
backpack ain't it
okay your packs here oh no I wanna be
dead and [ __ ] hey Owen
hey Owen better be wearing armor sup mr.
Krabs Owen
damnit
through the shark
this is open this time nice always in
the boat
how we doing on the speedrun I don't get
in the boat
oh and are you serious I gotta find a
ladder
why can't they Oh Owen
look away
oh and dad Isaac send to you after me he
didn't I came where's all this take her
part I'm gonna fix her back up I see huh
I feel like yeah fishing boat is not a
bad place to be you could fish off the
boat live off the sea he's dead
drink your own pee figured you wanna
tell me what happened
we were cleaning out of a small camp
it's just a couple scars and hit this
long on the head part
and he goes down and his weapons right
there
and he doesn't go for it instead he
turns to me he's old and tired he was
just
ready
go wash cars yeah
I couldn't do it all I haven't been
streaming of course damage it's my
[ __ ] three hours that's not bad
I told him I'm done he can do it himself
if he wants [ __ ] gun at me
so I grabbed it and then first I didn't
even know which one of us was shot
that's some heavy [ __ ] man
now let's go back you defended yourself
I can fix this
I'll talk to Isaac I'm tired happy I
don't have a fight over there [ __ ] I'm
going to Santa Barbara
the chaser rumor let's examine a Barbara
the fireflies aren't regrouping they're
gone it's a lead
oh god what's about to happen oh no this
is the hentai you should be safe sure
okay
I'll talk in the morning when you're
sober dog doo doo what dream be like I'm
[ __ ] insane you feel the same way if
the fireflies are in Santa Barbara I got
the opposite [ __ ] direction
alright the fireflies in what all good
sorry I grew up you should try it oh
yeah how do I hey he's drunk
should I go find the people that killed
my family you must be really drawn into
him
I could torture them until they're
crying oh no
[Music]
one wrong move and next oh snap snap oh
oh oh okay oh look away please Jesus
Christ oh my god what these days oh my
god they went straight for it okay what
[Music]
[Laughter]
the game that keeps on giving
thank you last of us that was very
tasteful thank you how many hours left
guys but they can't keep doing this to
us
for anyone that just joined that's been
eight hours of that we got two hours
more of that
all right
the monetize thank you Naughty Dog very
cool what a way is this right I I
thought people were lying at least it
wasn't that long
go straight all this game doesn't which
is fine by the way I think it's good but
what the [ __ ] was a burro she must have
been really worked out for that is
sliding right away in Jesus
Oh No
there's a lot left
how much left I can't do any more I
can't do it guys
doesn't matter chat is here are they
married now
yeah sure
premarital sex in The Last of Us
that's a yikes that's a big [ __ ]
yikes
for me
[Music]
I'm not gonna sit here and pretend I'm
okay with that night now you've gone too
[ __ ] far last of us okay
halfway done that's the time during this
why should I go to ten more minutes I
can do ten more minutes
where do I put it just across I have
stars in my eyes they are broken it
wasn't that bad you guys made it seem
way worse I mean I don't do I want to
see it again no nothing will ever more
are there more oh God
no more or safe gamers hey remember ton
of him I was not paying attention I
gotta sell that oh [ __ ]
hey you ship required ok
[Music]
where do I go oh it's gone the grass
snake time the better part of the game
comes up in two hours okay nice do I
have a silence nope we went to all fire
fire power okay this is not where you're
supposed to go cuz they're giving the
items snake gang
[Music]
maybe up here
and jump across to anything
jump there and jump there No
where do I go in there
yeah that would make sense
they can't see ma'am on the ground I can
maybe I should throw a break
well [ __ ] there's so many of them I do
have one crossbow
everyone came for the sex scene that's
what everyone wanted understandable
third guy made it so far it's gonna
chill here go away goddamn it [ __ ] maybe
it's just better to shoot them now [ __ ]
I should restart it you're right
throw the apps we did a game where's
maybe if I shoot one over here Thank You
ed Gary sorry I died a guy I try my I
try my best [ __ ] axe guy just went on
me okay we're almost there
he's right for this girl I don't have my
break anymore I ELISA shoot this guy
[Music]
what they heard me about the point
and crashed ships they definitely saw me
oh thank you this is how the pros do it
[Music]
you just make a pile sand money you can
pile up this is how the game was
intended to play man they do do they
breathe them somewhere how is he
shooting you like Oh didn't see you
there pal
only got down this is so sad sorry that
was painful
my bad gamers is this because I want to
just because I'm supposed to go just
wanted to get through this part
don't squeeze your fingers okay I'll
just end it here and we'll pick up next
time thank you for joining I'll be on
time next time I promise
I still enjoy playing it's still fun
appreciate you guys being here it's a
good good time next up more sex scenes
more dragged out [ __ ] look forward
to it
let's finish the Abbi part next time
alright take care guys
Brooklyn yeah yeah is that my close
enough no I'm not
where's the camera there it is